so what her parents are believing that
their straight daughter brought home
her lesbian friend for christmas they
also think that i'm
that i'm straight have they ever met a
lesbian
my name is cleo duval and i am the
director and co-writer of happiest
season
i am a huge fan of holiday movies
and i also love rom-coms but i had never
seen my experience represented in
those genres but then once i started you
know transitioning from
acting into writing and directing kind
of hit me that
i could be the person who could tell
that story you know it's a romantic
comedy and
you know it needs to have those like big
comedic moments from where
i'm really not interested in meeting
anyone tonight i am
harper's family you know kind of was
born from that just like
what is the family that you're gonna go
home to in this situation
and it's going to just be everyone say
christmas
no don't say that just smile the most
uncomfortable blurry boring
nope nope nope okay none of these will
do
uh we will try again tomorrow came out
to
my mom on christmas day we were in the
middle of a fight
and it just flew out of my mouth me
saying something along the line of
you don't know me at all and then my
mom's saying
yes i do and then me saying
well yeah but did you know so and so is
my girlfriend
and then both of us freezing and being
like oh
oh no what just happened and then after
what felt like three and a half hours my
mother just saying
no i didn't know that and then walking
out of the room and then we just never
talked about it again
we were able to repair it so that was
like the good news
it was not great until later in life
when i got into my 20s
what are you doing in the closet what
was so important to me in this story was
to not
vilify anyone
so sloane and eric you guys make gift
baskets right
no we create curated gift experiences
inside of handmade reclaimed wood
vessels because coming out is not
an easy thing to do no matter who you
are no matter where you come from
we all have the opportunity to reach the
other side
and you know and still deserve to be
loved and deserve to be accepted and
even if the people around us don't
always handle it exactly the right way
immediately it doesn't mean that they
can't also grow and that they can't also
change
every queer person has gone through it
and you know knows what that feeling is
of you know not being out wherever you
are
in that process be nice to yourself like
you're going through something that
is not going to last forever and you
need to love yourself through it you
have an idea like i want to come out
this you know
holiday season i'm gonna do it and if
you get there and
it doesn't feel like the right thing
that's okay there's no rush
it's also really important to find
outlets in the community
you know whether it's like friends or
however young people communicate
i don't know tic toc what are you doing
on your phone i left a gentleman alone
in my apartment so i'm tracking him to
make sure he leaves
you're tracking him yeah i track
everybody if the nsa can do it so can i
don't be afraid to reach out our
community is so amazing and you will
inevitably find
support even in places you might not
expect it
yes i am john abby's
heterosexual ex-boyfriend and i have
come to
get her back